we're glad to give this 2500 macbook  away to one of you guys my heart is  beating i'm excited for you guys which  one is it and the winner is  matthew ceo  sorry  your name his comment says i can't  believe how fast that bend base model is  wow double exclamation marks hey  matthew how's it going this is your  lucky day  out of thirty thousand  over thirty thousand comments on that  video you are the winner thank you for  watching our videos thank you for  commenting subscribe  thank you man we appreciate we  appreciate it i can totally use the  performance of this perfect there you go  that's awesome we're so glad yes man  yeah congratulations we'll get off the  call get your contact info and get that  sent right over to you man  that's awesome i'm super stoked awesome  thank you matthew congratulations thank  you